the presidents mar-a-lago resort had
another security breach months before a
woman from China bypassed the Secret
Service there University of Wisconsin
student mark Lynn Baum pleaded guilty
yesterday to entering mar-a-lago last
fall while the president was there Paula
Reed is at the White House with more on
this story Paula what did the suspect
have to say in court yesterday he told
the judge Gail that he had no evil
intention and he decided to sneak into
the president's private club just to see
if he could and according to court
documents it was pretty easy which helps
explain why this is the second intrusion
in just the past six months he admits
that on November 23rd while the first
family was spending Thanksgiving at the
resort he snuck in through a tunnel that
connects the beach and the President's
Club before he entered the tunnel he was
screened by Secret Service but then
walked right onto the property
he was eventually detained after the
Secret Service says they noticed his
behavior seemed out of place a Secret
Service spokesman says Lynn Blom did not
have any contact with the first family
but his intrusion was several months
before a Chinese woman allegedly snuck
into the club in March saying she was
there for an event
she has pleaded not guilty to lying to
agents Lindblom has been sentenced to
one years probation so well is anybody
concerned about security at mar-a-lago
when are they doing anything about it
absolutely Gail the ease with which this
teenager was able to access the
president's club while he was there on a
whim raises a lot of questions about
what kind of access sophisticated
adversaries could gain the prosecutor in
this case did say that security at
mar-a-lago has been stepped up after the
March incident the president expressed
his confidence in the Secret Service
calling them fantastic people Tony
Paula thank you of course it's a private
club so you could always buy your way in
that door yeah